[Music]
good evening we'll have those stories in
just a moment but first tonight as many
as two dozen people
forced from their homes after a fire as
investigators tried to figure out what
happened
thanks for joining us here at 11 i'm
denise valdez so all of this is
unfolding at the greenville park
apartments which is right in the middle
of the valley at
valley view in sahara orco mana joining
us there live now with the details orco
well denise the good news is that no
injuries were reported
in tonight's fire but the damage to the
building is extensive that second story
unit up there
completely gutted this photo from las
vegas fire and rescue
showing black smoke billowing out of
that unit when crews first got here
we're told the fire was contained
to the second story apartment but around
24 people who live here
were still displaced firefighters were
called out just before 7
30 tonight and were able to put out the
fire relatively quickly
the damage to the unit is estimated at
about 35
thousand dollars the red cross is
helping the people who were displaced
tonight
and the cause of the fire is still
undetermined at this point
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now